This lecture is about the evaluation of
taxable categorization.
So we've talked about many different
methods for taxi categorisation, but
how do you which method works better?
And for a particular application, how
do you this is the best way of solving
your problem.
To understand these will have to.
How to we have to know how to evaluate
categorisation results?
So first some general thoughts about
the evaluation in general for
evaluation of this kind of empirical
tasks such as categorisation, we use
methodology that was developed in 1960s
by information retrieval researchers
called Cranfield Evaluation
Methodology.
The basic idea is to help humans to
create test collection.
Where we already every document is
tagged with the desired categories, or
in the case of search for which query,
which documents should have been
retrieved and this is called ground
truth.
Now with this ground truth test
collection, we can then reduce the
collection to test many different
systems and compare different systems.
We can also turn off some component in
system to see what's going to happen.
Basically it provides.
A way to do controlled experiments to
compare different methods.
So this methodology has been virtually
used for all the tasks that involve
empirically defined problems.
So in our case, then we're going to
compare our systems categorization
results with the categorisation ground
truth created by humans.
And we're going to compare our systems
decisions on which documents should get
which category with what.
Categories have been assigned to those
documents by humans and we want to
quantify the similarity of these
decisions.
Or equivalently, to measure the
difference between the system output
and desired ideal output generated by
the humans?
So obviously the higher similarity is,
the better the results are.
The similarity can be measured in
different ways.
And that would lead to different
measures, and sometimes it's desirable
also to measure the similarity from
different perspectives just to have a
better understanding of the results in
detail.
For example, it might be also
interested in knowing which category
performs better, which category is easy
to categorize, etc.
In general, different categorization
mistakes, however, have different costs
for a specific application, so some
errors might be more serious than
others.
So ideally we would like to model such
differences.
But if you read many papers in texture
catalyzation, you will see that they
don't generally do that, and instead
they will use a simplified measure.
And that's the cause.
It's often OK not to consider such a
cost variation when we compare
different methods.
An we when we are interested in knowing
the relative difference of these
methods.
So it's OK to introduce some bias as
long as the bias is not correlated with
a particular method.
And then we should still expect the
more effective method to perform better
than a less effective one, even though
the measure is not perfect.
So the first measure that we will
introduce is called classification
accuracy, and this is basically to
measure the percentage of corrective
decisions.
So here you show that here you see that
there are K categories denoted by C1
through CK and there are N documents in
order by D1 through DN an for each pair
of a category on the document that we
can then look at the situation.
And see if the system has said yes to
despair.
Basically has assigned this category to
this document or no, so this is denoted
by Y or N.
That's the system to decision.
And similarly we can look at the humans
decision.
Also, if the human has assigned a
category to the document, there will be
a plus sign here.
That's just that just means a human
would think this assignment is correct
an if the incorrect, and then there's a
minus.
So we will see.
All combinations of these ends yes and
Nos with minus and plus.
So there are four combinations in total
and two of them are correct and when we
have Y plus or minus and then there are
also two kinds of errors.
So the measure of classification
accuracy is similar to count how many
of these decisions are correct and
normalize that by the total number of
decisions we have made.
So we know that the total number of
decisions is.
In multiplied by K.
And the number of characters decisions
obviously are basically of two kinds.
One is why pluses and the other is N
minus is and we just put together the
account.
Now this is a very convenient measure
that will give us a one number to
characterize performance of method and
the higher the better of course.
But the method I also had some
problems.
First it has treated all the decisions
equally so, but in reality there's some
decision errors are more serious than
others.
For example, it may be more important
to get the decisions right on some
documents than others, and or maybe
more important to get the divisions
right on some categories than others,
and this would call for some detailed
evaluation of this results to
understand.
The strengths and weaknesses of
different methods.
And to understand the performance of
these methods in detail.
In APA category or per document basis?
One example that shows clearly the
desicion errors are having different
causes, spam filtering that could be
retrieved as a two category
categorization problem.
Missing a legitimate email is all is 1
type of error.
But letting us ma'am to come into your
folder is another type of error.
The two types of errors are clearly
very different because it's very
important not to miss a legitimate
email.
It's OK to occasionally let us spam
email to come into your inbox, so the
error of the first missing a legitimate
email is very high cost.
It's very serious mistake.
And classification error classification
accuracy does not address this issue.
There's also another problem with
imbalanced tests at the Imagine there's
a skew.
The test set where most instances are
in category one.
And 98% of instances are in category
one only 2% are in category Two.
In such a case, we can have a very
simple baseline that actually performs
very, and the baseline would Simply put
all instances in the major category.
That would give us 98% accuracy.
In this case, it's going to be
appearing to be very effective, but in
reality this is obviously not a good
result.
And so, in general, when we use
classification accuracy as a measure,
we want to ensure that the classes are
balanced.
And we wonder about equal number of
instances.
For example, in each class the minority
categories or classes tend to be
overlooked in the evaluation of
classification accuracy.
How to address these problems?
We of course would like to also
evaluate the results in other ways and
in different ways.
As I said, it's beneficial to look at
the actual must multiple perspectives.
So for example, we can look at the
perspective from each document
perspective based on each document.
So the question here is, how could
other divisions on this document?
Now, as in the general cases of all
decisions, we can think about four
combinations of possibilities.
Depending on whether the system has
said yes, and depending on whether the
human has said it correctly or
incorrectly, or say yes or no, and so
the four combinations are first.
When both the human system said yes and
that's true positives when the system
says yes, it's actually positive.
So when the system says yes, it's a
positive.
But when the human confirmed that it is
indeed correct, that becomes true
positive.
When the system says yes, but human
says no, that's incorrect.
That's a false positive FP.
And when the system says no, but the
human says yes, then it's a false
negative.
We missed one assignment.
When does the system and human said no?
Then that's also corrected vision.
That's true negatives.
Alright, so then we can have some
meshes to just better characterize the
performance by using these phone
numbers and so 2 popular measures of
precision and recall.
And these are also proposed by
information retrieval researchers in
19, six days for evaluating searching
results.
But now they have become a standard
measure used everywhere.
So when the system says yes, we can ask
the question how many are correct?
What's the percentage of correct
decisions when the system says yes?
That's called precision.
It's a true positive divided by all the
cases when the system says yes all the
positives.
The other recall the other meshes
called Recall an this measures.
Whether the document that has called
all the categories it should have.
So in this case it's divided the true
positive by true positives and false
negatives.
So these are all the cases where this
human says the document should have
this category.
So this represents the old categories
that it should have got an.
So recall tells us whether the system
has actually indeed assigned all the
categories that it should have to this
document.
This gives us a detailed view of the
decision on each document.
Then we can aggregate them later.
And if you're interested in some
documents and this would tell us how
well we did that those documents a
subset of them might be more
interesting than others.
For example, and this allows us to
analyze errors in more detail as well.
We can separate the documents of
certain characteristic from others and
then look at the errors.
You might see a pattern here for this
kind of documents along documents it
doesn't do as well as.
For short documents.
And this gives you some insight for
improving the better.
Similarly, we can look at the popular
category valuation.
This.
In this case we're going to look at the
how good are the decision on a
particular category.
And as in the previous case, we can
define precision and recall and it will
just basically answer the questions
from a different perspective.
I saw when the system says yes, how
many are corrected that means looking
at this category to see if all the
documents that are assigned with this
category are indeed in this category.
An recall would tell us has the
category being actually assigned to all
the documents that should have this
category.
Is sometimes also useful to combine
precision and recall as one measure,
and this is often done by using if
mesh.
And this is just the harmonic mean of
precision and recall defined on this
slide.
Ann
It's also controlled by a parameter
beta two to indicate the weather
precision is more important, or recall
is more important when beta is set to
one, we have a measure called F1, and
in this case we just take a equal
weight on both precision and recall.
If one is very often used as a measure
for categorisation.
Now, as in all cases when we combine
results, you always should think about
the best way of combining them.
So in this case I don't know if you
have thought about it and we could have
combining them just with the arithmetic
mean, right?
So that would still give it the same
range of values.
But obviously there's a reason why we
didn't do that and why.
If one is more popular and it's
actually useful to think about
difference.
And if you think about that, you will
see that there is indeed some
difference and sum.
Undesirable property of this arithmetic
mean.
Basically, it would be obvious to you
if you think about a case when the
system says yes for all the category
and nothing appears.
And even tried to compute the precision
and recall in that case and see what
would happen.
I basically this kind of measure will
not the arithmetic mean is not going to
be as reasonable FF1, which tends to
prefer a tradeoff between precision and
recall.
So that the two values are about equal,
so we if there's an extreme case where
you have 041 value and one for the
other, than F1 will be low, but the
arithmetic mean would still be
reasonably high.